Joe sighed to himself quietly, looking out
of the window at the still, silent stretch
of highway snaking through the desert only
to disappear somewhere over the horizon.
The sun was slowly crawling down, almost completely
vanished from sight, and he knew when it was
gone, there’d be no light left in the desert.
It wasn’t the same kind of darkness you
found in a city, there they had streetlights
and cars whizzing through with their headlights
on full blast.
It never really got dark in the cities, but
out here, nothing but true, pitch-black darkness
for miles around, only alleviated when the
sky was clear enough for the stars to shine
through, or broken by the beams of a passing
car speeding down the highway.
Giving another sigh, Joe sipped on his coffee;
by this point, it was lukewarm to match the
dropping temperature outside and bitter to
the taste.
But he needed the caffeine to keep himself
awake.
After all, he had a long night ahead of him,
but then again, they were all long nights
in this line of work.
This was the only diner for miles around,
and he had no idea just how many hours it
would be before he next got to eat or drink
anything.
With an almost empty pot with the last dregs
of coffee in one hand, the waitress came up
to Joe at his table.
It was the last spot in the diner with anyone
still sitting in it.
“Closing time,” she told him with a tired
smile.
“One for the road?”
Nodding, Joe lifted his travel mug for her
to fill.
As her workday was ending, his was about to
start.
He grabbed his jacket and slung it over his
shoulder, leaving a few dollars as a tip on
the table before he made his way out of the
diner and over to his car.
Buckling into the driver’s seat, Joe took
a deep breath as he pulled his phone out of
his pocket, dreading the potential barrage
of notifications that would come flooding
through the second he did.
Opening up the corresponding app, he clocked
in for the night, and sure enough, was instantly
met with a veritable tidal wave of requests.
Grumbling quietly to himself, he tapped ‘Accept’
on the first one he saw, and turned the key
in the ignition.
Working as a driver for a carpool and ride-sharing
service was far from a simple job at the best
of times, but even more so in this particular
area of the Southwestern United States.
The state of New Mexico shared a border not
only with Texas but with Chihuahua, one of
the Northmost states of Mexico.
Being so close to that border meant that most
of the calls and requests for lifts that Joe
received on an average night meant he needed
to bounce back and forth between the US and
Mexico, crossing the border at his clients’
request – legally, of course.
We’re not going all Breaking Bad here today.
Some nights weren’t so complicated; someone
might just need a quick ride from Doña Ana
to the town of Truth or Consequences - a New
Mexico town named after, we kid you not, a
TV game show.
Sure, that might have been a seventy-five-mile
drive up the I-25, but at least it didn’t
involve crossing from El Paso into the city
of Juarez.
At this time of night, it was nowhere near
as busy as during the day.
But even so, that didn’t make hopping back
and forth over the border, and all the red
tape it entailed, any less of an arduous process,
especially stuck behind the wheel of a car
for hours on end.
Tonight, however, wasn’t a simple night.
Joe’s first call was for a pickup from a
couple whose flight had been rerouted to the
international airport in Juarez.
They seemed to be newlyweds and demanded to
be taken all the way back to a hotel in Las
Cruces, making it abundantly clear they didn’t
want to stay closer to the airport and outright
refusing when Joe offered to recommend them
some nearby hotels.
Getting to know most of the area around the
three-way intersection between New Mexico,
Texas, and the Mexican Border after driving
around it so many times, he’d gotten to
know the area pretty well.
Unfortunately, not everyone wanted to hear
a display of Joe’s local knowledge; most
of them just wanted him to drive them in silence.
Next up, a group of rowdy guys, real frat
house types from the University of El Paso,
Texas, wanted to be taken to a bar halfway
across the city.
A bit more of a straightforward trip, Joe
thought, although he could have done without
them drunkenly chanting ‘Spring Break’
at the top of their lungs every five minutes.
After that, it was another jaunt across the
border, this time transporting a suit and
Stetson-wearing Texan gentleman to Horizon
City.
He spent the whole ride on his phone, talking
at length about a business deal he’d just
closed, not saying a word to Joe the entire
time.
Doug Dimmadome, eat your heart out.
The next person to request a lift wasn’t
much more talkative either, she was a twenty-something
girl who plainly stated she just wanted to
get far away from Sierra Blanca.
Hours and hours had ticked by since Joe had
left the diner, the last of the coffee in
his travel mug having been finished long before.
His next ride request had come through and
required him to once again make the drive
out to the other side of the border.
By this point, the evening had turned into
night and was now approaching the earliest
hours of the following morning, the desert
still filled with nothing but deep, inky blackness.
The same desert that had scorched acres upon
acres of skin, that had taken so many lives,
big and small, and picked the skin and flesh
from countless bones.
The desert can be a truly merciless place
at the best of times, but sometimes, there’s
a little something more out there, just waiting
for you.
Dark and hungry.
Occasionally, as he drove back towards El
Paso, Joe would see another car speeding towards
him on the other side of the highway, but
it was so dark that he could see nothing of
the driver.
Only their headlights were visible, right
up until they drove past him, everything behind
the hood of the oncoming car almost imperceptible
as it whizzed through the night.
Crossing the border so many times a night,
Joe had become friendly with a few of the
officers that patrolled the gates, waving
cars past after they’d shown the necessary
paperwork.
He was never usually held there for long enough
to start actual conversations with them, exchanging
only a friendly nod or one-liner with the
few Border Patrol guards whose names he could
still remember.
But sometimes, when things were a little quieter
at the gates, he’d overhear the odd passing
comment while his driver side window was rolled
down.
Tonight, as the long barrier in front of his
car was raised, Joe caught a few words coming
through on a radio belonging to one of the
guards, something vague about sightings of
‘phantom lights’.
He chuckled to himself, writing it off as
yet another alleged alien sighting.
Something about the desert at night really
seemed to capture people’s imaginations,
Joe thought to himself as he pulled away from
the border gate, heading for the I-10.
There were always stories like that circulating
around this area of New Mexico.
It was easy to see why, being so close to
Roswell, the home of Area 51; a United States
Air Force base that secretly housed alien
life forms and spaceships, allegedly at least,
if years of conspiracy believers and Facebook
memers are to be believed.
Every so often one of Joe’s passengers would
ask him about Unidentified Flying Objects
or he’d overhear them talking amongst themselves
about a slew of urban legends.
Phantom hitchhikers that would hitch rides
on the highway, only to vanish from the backseats
of cars.
And, of course, tales of disembodied floating
lights, either hovering way up in the sky
or just above the ground.
Regardless of whichever one was popular at
any given moment, Joe knew there were plenty
of weird and spooky stories coming out of
the desert.
What he was unaware of, however, was that
he was currently in one of his own.
He'd been so wrapped up in thoughts of what
he might do if one of the people that hired
him turned out to be a wandering spirit that
Joe didn’t even notice he had made a wrong
turn.
It was only by the virtue of glancing at his
car’s GPS that he even realized, and by
then it had been long enough since that he
was completely unsure how far back it was
that he had made such an error.
According to the map, he was… nowhere.
He hadn’t stopped, his car was still moving
at a steady speed down the long stretch of
asphalt, but the GPS didn’t show any road
at his current location.
He had no clue which part of which highway
he was even on.
Short on options, and short on time to get
to his next client for the night, Joe just
did what his job required of him: he kept
on driving.
Anyone watching from a distance would have
seen an empty, lengthy portion of the highway,
with but one single car traveling along it,
only the headlights both illuminating the
road in front of it… and giving away the
car’s position.
Slowing down slightly, just to play it safe,
Joe tried searching up where he was using
the maps app on his phone.
He figured he wouldn’t get stopped for checking
his phone while driving, or be much risk to
any other drivers on the road; after all,
it seemed like his was the only car around
for miles.
Even if he was still heading in near enough
the right direction for his next pickup, that
would be at least some saving grace.
Maybe the map on the car’s built-in GPS
was a little outdated, he thought, and that
was preventing this part of the highway from
showing up.
Connection to the internet was extremely limited
this far out in the New Mexico desert, and
by the time the map loaded, it didn’t provide
much in the way of new information or even
the slightest bit of comforting reassurance.
It only seemed to agree with the GPS that
Joe was well and truly lost.
As he took his free hand off the wheel for
a split second, just to try and zoom in on
the satellite view of the terrain, two bright,
white lights appeared in the distance.
Startled, Joe dropped his phone into the front
passenger seat, hearing it slip onto the floor
of the car as he gripped the steering wheel
again, both hands back at ten and two.
The lights were speeding in the opposite direction
he was driving in, a fair few feet ahead of
him, but still, it was another vehicle on
this otherwise empty, isolated stretch of
the highway.
A loud and sudden idea rang out in Joe’s
head; if he could signal what he had assumed
to be another approaching car, he could ask
the driver where exactly he was, and what
the quickest route to get back to the I-10
was.
He couldn’t guarantee he would make the
oncoming vehicle stop and help him, after
all, so few people would willingly trust a
stranger on the highway.
But considering his only other options were
to either keep driving along this seemingly
endless road, or to turn back around and try
to find wherever it was he’d made the wrong
turning in the first place, needless to say
Joe’s hands were a little tied.
Tapping the appropriate switch affixed to
his wheel, he flickered his own headlights
on and off, in an effort to catch the other
driver’s attention.
Nothing, the pair of headlights kept their
current course, both theirs and Joe’s traveling
parallel to each other as if they were about
to joust with their beams of light.
Hitting the switch again, Joe tried lowering
his headlight’s setting and then raising
it back to full brightness.
Still no reaction from the other driver.
He pushed the emergency button, that activated
both the front and rear lights of the car,
but this only yielded the same result.
Deciding there was nothing else that he could
do, Joe gently pulled his vehicle over, parking
abruptly at the side of the highway.
He instinctively checked his rearview, only
to remember there wasn’t anyone behind,
just him and the apparently oblivious driver
approaching ahead.
In a last-ditch effort to get their attention,
Joe punched the car horn, rolling down his
window in order to listen for a response.
The blaring noise echoed through the empty
desert night, a loud and sustained blast followed
by a beat of silence as Joe paused, waiting
to hear the same sound back from the oncoming
vehicle.
He squinted at it through the dark.
It was still pretty far, but closing rapidly.
Or, as far as he could tell it was, all he
had to go on was the advancing lights, with
nothing visible behind them.
Joe leaned out of his window, hoping that
would somehow give him better visibility through
the sheer darkness of a desert at night.
It did as little to improve things as a second,
much longer blast of his horn did.
The other driver still didn’t react.
By now, the lights were close enough that
whoever was behind the other wheel would be
able to see Joe.
And yet, they didn’t do anything to change
their speed, didn’t flicker their lights
back or sound their own horn.
Nothing, just the same two points of light;
they might as well have been floating just
above the ground given how they obscured what
was behind them.
At this point, Joe was certain they were close
enough to see him now, little more than a
few feet in front of his stationary car and
still closing at a sustained speed.
Getting agitated, he went to hit his horn
a third time, when he noticed something…
or rather, he noticed something that he hadn’t.
This car, hurtling towards him through the
night, wasn’t making any sound.
It wasn’t just that the other driver deliberately
hadn’t returned the signals Joe had been
trying to give; there was no noise coming
from it whatsoever.
No grumbling of an engine, nor the rolling
of rubber tires against the asphalt surface
of the highway.
It was silent, just the pair of ominous lights
soundlessly racing through the night…
heading straight for where Joe was sat, parked
still; a sitting duck, like he was defenseless
prey.
Violently turning the key in the ignition,
Joe slammed his foot down on the accelerator.
His car spluttered to life and careened down
the road.
He was heading straight for the other car
– if it even was a car – hoping to shoot
straight past it and take his chances continuing
along the highway alone.
The lights were almost on top of him now,
still too bright to make out anything behind
them.
But there was still no engine noise, nothing
to indicate what the hell it even was… until
one of them jumped onto the hood of his car.
An orb of light, attached to a thrashing shape
beneath, parted from the other.
It leaped through the air and came down right
in the path of Joe’s car, just as he was
about to pass what he’d first thought to
be another car.
The light smashed directly through the windshield,
Joe instinctively lifting an arm to cover
his face and protect his eyes from the impending
shower of broken glass.
But it was in that second that he took his
eyes off the road that the other light made
its move.
It had been perfectly parallel with Joe’s
car, only to turn, sharply and violently,
connecting with the driver’s side door with
enough force to not only dent the metal surface
but to completely lift the car up.
It barrelled sideways, tumbling over itself
off of the highway and into the surrounding
desert.
Trapped inside, bucked tight, Joe was thrown
about in his seat, unable to steady himself
as the car rolled.
His arm was still over his face, splinters
of glass showering over him.
The… whatever it was, was still thrashing
about, its glow illuminating the entire interior
of the car.
Until the whole vehicle came to a stop, landing
upside down, wheels in the air pointing up
at the cloudy night sky.
Hanging the wrong way up, Joe reached for
his seatbelt and unclasped it, his head instantly
dropping onto the ceiling of the upturned
car.
Through the shattered driver-side window,
he crawled out on his hands.
The pain was shooting through his whole body,
bruises and blood covering his arms, and the
intense, agonizing feeling of broken bones
on top of that.
Rolling over onto his back, Joe looked up
at the wreck of his car, his livelihood…
and the monster standing in front of it.
Illuminated fully for the first time by the
car’s still active headlights, the thing
had managed to pull itself free from the destroyed
windshield and was now pacing slowly around
the overturned hood.
It walked on two legs but didn’t move like
a man, in fact, it didn’t even look like
one.
It was like something pulled straight out
of prehistoric times, a pair of hinged limbs
supporting a streamlined reptilian body, with
hooked claws on its feet.
Its back was arched, keeping itself low, as
its two arms stayed close to its center.
The creature had almost human-like hands,
but each finger was tipped with long, pointed
talons.
But its head was what Joe saw first, what
he had seen at a distance and mistaken for
car headlights only a few minutes ago.
In the place he would’ve expected to see
a pair of slitted eyes staring at him, was
a bulbous mass of a head.
Bio-luminescent light glowed from beneath
the monster’s skin, a brain visible amongst
a web of bright organs… and beneath that,
a wide, gaping maw of sharp teeth.
Joe noticed another light drawing near, brightening
the area where he lay defenseless.
The second of the raptor-like monsters was
pacing closer to him, both their glowing heads
kept low to the ground, ready to strike.
***
“Yep, looks pretty clear to me,” one of
the men disguised as a Highway Patrol officer
announced.
“Handprints match up with what their front
paws look like, no trace of the driver.
Just a big wreck in the middle of nowhere.”
“Better get on the horn to control then,”
his colleague replied, wearing a similar uniform.
“I thought SCP-745s were only found a little
north of here.”
“We shut off the section of the highway
they usually show up at,” the first Foundation
agent explained casually, sipping his coffee
as he looked at the upturned wreckage of Joe’s
car; his body was nowhere to be found.
“But every now and then, a couple of them
will show up a bit away from there.
One of them wouldn’t come this far into
the south of New Mexico on its own though.”
“Oh, because of the lights, right?”
his fellow agent responded, the two of them
walking back towards their car.
“Their heads, they mimic car headlights
or something.”
“Well, there’s that,” the first man
nodded, taking one last look at the long,
open desert around them, and the highway stretching
through it.
“Plus it must get lonely traveling out here
on your own.”
Now go and check out “SCP-1265 THE MESOZOIC
PRESERVE” and “SCP-682 TERRIFYING TEST
LOGS” to continue on a Jurassic journey
filled with more rampaging reptilian creatures
and other ravenous raptor-like anomalies!